[موسيقى]
في جنوب شرقي البحر الكريم تقع دوله سان
فانسنت والجرينادين جزرها البالغ عددها 32
جزيره
هنا ست جزر فقط ماهوله بالسكان ترتبط
ببعضها بواسطه هذا القارب القديم
جزيره سان فانزنت هي جزيره بركانيه ذات
غابه كثيفه يسكن فيها نحو 100 الف نسمه
وهي القلب الاقتصادي والسياسي للبلد
واليها يتوافد سكان بقيه الجزر لشراء
طعامهم واحتياجاتهم وكل ما هو ضروري لهم
عبر الابحار على متن قارب قديم يطلق عليه
باراكودا
للقيام ببعض التسوق شراء الطعام هذا النوع
من الاشياء انا انقل سلع الاستهلاكيه
اليومي بشكل اساسي لانه ليس لدينا العديد
من المتاجر على الجزر خاصه عندما يتعلق
الامر بالادوات المنزليه لذلك استقل
القارب مرتين شهريا للعثور على مجموعه
اكبر من البضائع
تم بناء باراكودا عام
1962 في حوض بناء السفن في بركن النرويجيه
السفينه مياه المضيق النرويجيه في عام
ووصلت الى البحر الكاريبي
باراكودا تربط الجزر ببعضها خمس مرات في
الاسبوع على مدار 36 عاما تحت قياده
الكابتن جيفري كينج نحن نعمل لصالح
الحكومه نقوم بالابحار في يومي الاثنين
والثلاثاء اما الاربعاء فنتركه لنقوم
بالصيانه ونعمل في يومي الخميس والجمعه من
جديد في يوم الاحد نقوم بعمل المعاملات
الورقيه البرنامج هو كالتالي جزيره كانوان
ثم مايرو ومن ثم جزيره يونيون ثم لدينا
نصف ساعه من اجل تفريغ الحموله ونعود
مباشره الى سانت فين سان دون توقف
[موسيقى]
اتيني من الابحار تصبح جزيره كانوان على
مرمى البصر وعلى رصيف مينائها يستعد
الجميع لشراء احتياجاتهم في اسرع وقت ممكن
بصاحب هذا القارب من قبل ملكه انجلترا كي
يقوم بتقديم هذه الخدمه لشعب جرينالين
ولقد قام بذلك لسنوات عديده هذه العباره
مهمه جدا لانها كما ترون تتيح للناس ان
يقوموا بجلب منتجاتهم من سانت فين سنت الى
هنا
يتجول القارب بين الجزر حاملا السكان
والبضائع والعمال وجميع الرحلات يجب ان
تكون بالنهر ولا تسمح الحكومه للقبطان
بالابحار له
قصه الحب التي جمعت قاربه باراكودا
المعمره والقبطان جيفري كينج توشيك على
نهايتها
ويرغب في توريث حب القارب لابنه رودني
ليخلفه في الابحار
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]